right now that we have just really taken
time to focus on our thought process our
processing where we mentally and
emotionally are before we are addressing
that with everyone else because I think
that's the smartest thing that you can
do in any situation and now Lindsey
Chrisley's ready to share how she feels
about her parents Todd and Julie
Chrisley's prison sentence if you want
to speak and for whatever to be heard or
believed then you have to be accepting
of the fact that the other side is going
to have something to say too in an
exclusive statement to Hollywood Life
the 33 year old says she wanted to take
a step back to process everything before
speaking out adding quote the past few
months have been extremely hard for me
and my family and I am heartbroken over
the updates in my parents case that
occurred late last month I believe that
everything that happens
God already knows it's going to happen
and God he knows how you're going to get
through it in November Todd was served a
12-year sentence in Julie 7 plus they'll
also both serve 16 months probation and
Lindsay says since the news drops some
of the media has tried to twist her
response to it but says there's no T
here quote I am heartbroken and
navigating this process the best way I
know how at the end of the day this is a
real family and these are real and raw
emotions with that being said thank you
for all your love support and prayers
we're gonna do what we've always done
which is come together as a team and see
what happens during the family's
struggles the bond between Todd and
Lindsay was restored after the two were
previously estranged there was just some
kind of emotional
battle that Lindsay has had within
herself I moved away from something that
I felt was toxic and not in my best
interest and hurt my own path tough
times like Todd's convictions and
Lindsay's divorce have seemingly enabled
the two to put the drama in the past
after my divorce stuff had become public
my dad had posted I'm here I love you
whatever's going on in your life right
now I see it so that's really more so
how we were able to reconnect everything
happens for a reason and then the timing
that it's supposed to as far as how the
holidays are looking for the Chrisley
Bunch well Lindsay expects things won't
be the same this year in my family we've
always done Christmas like very big and
it's always been like a very exciting
time of year and you know our house was
always decorated very magical and my
parents always like were the best at
Christmas
and so I mean obviously with everything
going on with my family things just like
look a lot different this year and
Lindsay she's just ready for a fresh
start I'm like you know what I'm kind of
ready for it to all be over I'm ready
for it to be a new year there's been so
many things that have gone on that I'm
just kind of over it and ready to start
fresh and have a little bit of a break
[Music]